there are indeed a lot of things that
could happen for trevor lawrence as he
takes a look at the 2020 standings and
he sees new york jets
new york giants and other bad and
dysfunctional teams
but that's how it always is unless
there's a trade
the team that's at the top of the stack
is at the top of the stack
for a reason do we read anything into
this is he maybe suggesting that he
would play
college football one more year to try to
avoid this morass of bad teams that
would be vying for his services chris
i i don't i don't i mean and again i i
that was the first time i saw the clip
you know
reading reading is is a little different
uh but even reading it i just
i felt like no it's a guy that's just
trying to
not make any headlines hey it's football
i'm worried about my team right now
kind of one of those type of things i'll
evaluate that as we go forward
again you know hey when you're that guy
yeah there's never going to be
a beautiful team on the horizon never
but you know i always look at it this
way you know first off playing in new
york is pretty damn special
you know i i can speak to that as
experience they treat my dad like he's a
damn god up here
and he's he was good but he ain't god
all right i know that
and you know so so that
is something special and the other thing
i'll say too i think you know
as a competitor as a player a lot of
there would be a yearning to go to a
place sometimes
that hasn't been great where you can go
there
and now set forth the new winning
culture
and you do become a legend in that town
you know hey i look at joe burrow
he's got a chance to do that baker in
cleveland you know it looked like he
brought that on hey who cares we were
owen 16 whatever we're gonna be better
now that i'm here
there's something about that hey brady
in new england that was never like a
great place
but him belichick go there you get
something going all of a sudden it's the
greatest place in the world so
you know you just can't tell what the
future holds who knows who they hire as
a head coach at the end of the year the
new york jets and all those things
i would expect them to come out i think
you're rolling the dice is a lot more if
you stay in
and maybe get hurt and who the hell
knows what happens after that
i look at it this way if he is having
misgivings about any of these teams i
would much rather see him
make a power play then go back and play
football
for another year sure whatever he does
next year right he should not play at
clemson
sorry clemson fans but that's not under
any set of circumstances
what he should do what he should do is
make it known
that he reserves the right to sit out
the whole year
and re-enter the draft in 2022
if he doesn't like who's picked him and
if the team that picks him refuses to
trade him
he can sit out the whole year he can
re-enter the draft now the problem is
there's no guarantee there isn't going
to be a bad team
that takes you next year but once you've
shown that you're willing to sit out the
whole year
maybe teams take a little more seriously
and
and and that's how you you leverage a
trade
to a team that you want to play for
because look
even if you say
i don't want to play for the jets and
the jets say too bad
we're drafting you well i don't want to
play for you i got another choice so
i'll sign the contract and i'll come
play
but you know i don't want to i don't
want to be there
i'm not going to do all the stuff that
you want me to do i'm not going to show
up early i'm not going to stay late
i mean that's the thing there's a pride
that goes into it that there is a way to
to to posture it so they wouldn't want
you yeah
sure but i think right the
competitiveness
eventually is going to take over and
you're going to resign yourself to your
fate
and you're going to go try to make
chicken salad that's what but still
but still yeah i i i
i wish more guys who have real leverage
and joe blow
burrow flirted with it last year and i
know this makes bengals fans mad but i'm
telling you
he flirted with the idea of making a
power play to not play for the bengals
and you could look at what's going on
now and say
he deserves better maybe he should have
because he's got it
and there aren't many other guys on the
roster other than joe mixon that do
no they don't they got some receivers
around them we're seeing them put up
some numbers so
they're building something there yes
where they've done him a disservice and
where i would be concerned if i was mike
brown or anything i'd be calling the
offensive coaching staff in and going
i just picked the guy number one and he
might be dead by week 17.
you guys are getting him freaking killed
that would be my biggest concern
you know and that's always a concern for
a young quarterback going to a bad team
and doing all that
so that's where they need to fix joe
burrow because hey yeah it's
he's great you got your guy let's not
make sure his career is ruined by
getting
killed so early on in his career that it
doesn't last as long as it should or he
gets some crazy injury
so we'll see where it goes trevor
lawrence is special we know that
i would say hey everybody's amazed with
what you've seen from justin herbert so
far right
trevor lawrence is justin herbert but
probably another notch above as far as
talent is concerned
that's type of player we're talking
about you know it can be
50 and 60 yard lasers through the air
like we see justin herbert and you just
go whoa
it looked like he was throwing a five
yard out and he just threw that 60 yards
with that like nothing
or it could be like we saw against ohio
state him running for 55 yard touchdowns
with
okuda and all these other nfl players on
the field and they can't catch him
so he's a very very special talent let
alone he's played a lot of football and
a lot of big games
and they put the pressure on him to just
make plays it's not necessarily like a
surgical offense where it's just like oh
the system's great and boom boom boom
boom
no they're a little basic and they just
go our players are better than you and
he'll throw strikes and that receiver
will get open
and we just play that way and there's
room to grow with this kid
too that's where he's really a special
special uh
specimen i guess and and i think part of
the concern is guys don't want to
pass on the opportunity to be the first
overall pick because by next year
who knows and and who knows if the
system retaliates against you
come next year if you're the guy who
stands up and pokes the bear
and says i'm not signing your contract
i'm not playing your game
i'm not letting you pick me i'm picking
you
and i'll sit out a full year if i have
to prove my point
maybe he's not the first overall pick
the next year and
you know this is part of the system and
you know how i feel about the system i
know i don't think it's an
honor i don't think it's a good thing i
think the best thing is letting these
young men decide where they want to play
especially at the quarterback position
because where you
are drafted and where you spend those
first few years of your career
who you're learning from who your
teammates are what your circumstances
are are you being protected by the
offensive line
those are all factors in whether or not
you're going to become as good as you
can be
definitely and i i think some guys get
ruined who otherwise would have been
great they get ruined and we know now
because we see so many guys who come in
and they're great right out of the gates
the the uh grace period yeah
smaller and smaller and smaller right
and
and you're out you're done yeah you
don't you're not even a backup
before you get a chance to prove that
you can play no i i you you're
mike you're right and hey with the
rookie salary cap
on the contracts that way and the fact
that good quarterbacks are coming out
every year
i do think you're gonna see teams go
like oh it's been two or three years
this guy's not the next guy we might
draft him or there's another free agent
quarterback out there or whatever
hey we're in the era of yes players are
gonna make their own luck a little bit
they they have to we hold them
to a standard no matter even if the team
is crappy around them we don't want to
hear it
you know it's it's lebron james right
why should he stay on this crappy
cavaliers team and magic johnson got
lucky enough to get drafted by a team
that had karim al-jul-jabar michael
cooper byron scott
james worthy like that was he just got
lucky he got drafted by them
so yeah athletes are going to continue
to make
more moves to help them out that way
it's not in the football player or the
quarterback's dna
normally it's not they usually want to
go take the challenge on
you know well i'm going to build
something i'm really good i think we can
be special that way right
but we have seen elway manning a few
have played that and i don't know if
that's in trevor lawrence or not
yeah and it's amazing it's happened so
infrequently and for both guys who did
it
it did work out they got to where they
wanted to be
and and with eli manning you know you've
heard this story as well chris
number one archie ran interference for
eli it was eli that didn't be there it
wasn't dad
getting involved in being a helicopter
parent and saying i don't want you to be
in a in
in san diego but when eli visited he got
mixed signals as to whether or not they
really wanted him
right gm aj smith wanted him marty shot
and heimer got the sense he didn't those
two were at odds all the time he didn't
want to be part of that dysfunction
right so you can't blame them for that
and they have drew brees like what the
hell
so um i also wondered always if like the
fact that maybe the chargers
did they like uh ryan leaf more than a
peyton manning back in the day too did
that i always wondered if that played
into them not liking
the chargers either i i don't know that
i'm just throwing that out there
yeah and it isn't it amazing how close
that was right in 1998 between the two
and that just shows you how imperfect it
is but when you are the clear-cut
guy when you are the one you got a lot
more leverage
and joe burrow used that word at one
point back in january
you do have leverage why not use it and
maybe we're getting close to the point
where a player will use it and
and look i'm i i promise
any player out there now or in the
future that chooses to push back against
that notion that you must go along
with this draft process you must go to
whoever picks you as the first overall
pick in the draft you've got leverage
use it and i'll support you 100
of course it's your money that's on the
line not mine but still
still i i hope that trevor lawrence
hires an agent who can help him craft a
plan
that will let him go to where he wants
to be not to go to the team
that just says hey we have trevor and
now
you know let's let's let's see what we
can do
and let's hope that it works out he will
be the most sought after
number one pick in a while and i don't i
don't say that lightly but just with the
way the season's shaking out and how
good he is and the team he's been on and
everything like that i mean i i think
we're gonna have a war
for this kid at number one hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports